if you could be homeless in any city  where would you choose  that's a pretty good question definitely  new york city because well there's not a  dry butt  in this town apparently no man it's got  to be new york city because there's this  warm weather no you guys start walking  to like san diego or florida or some  [ __ ] i know using this video too  sorry  he's in my light no no definitely new  york city man there's a lot of places to  hide and i always feel like i feel like  you want to be in a city there's a lot  of places to hide there's a lot of  there's a lot of crevices and looks and  crannies i know guys who allegedly made  like 100 grand panhandling up there like  in the bronx my dad always told me never  trust the word of a panhandler he might  be bad at math  i made a zillion dollars